notre monde s'assombrit un peu plus
chaque jour une nouvelle organisation se
développe au moyen-orient et menace la
paix internationale soit tu es avec moi
soit tu comptes
un petit cercle des nations je suis
partant s'est réuni pour former le
conseil de sécurité du monde au pays
respectifs estime que vous êtes les
meilleurs
tous les civils
vous êtes tous morts no matter
d'amateurs segan clé sans tarder et on
les éliminera jusqu'au dernier pour le
retrouver
crois moi
ne doute pas de ma détermination
nous allons remporter cette guerre
c'est une banque salmon commandera
à
personne ne suivra
[Musique]
ils n'abandonneront jamais c'est ce
qu'on verra